Elijah has changed over the years. He's given up
We keep him heavily sedated, but there is a reason for that. He's too smart fo them.
You won't be lonely anymore. We have two new friends
The three of you think you have extraordinary gifts like something out of a comic book
I've developed an effective treatment for this disorder
the light will force a different identity to take over
Step away from the controls now little duckling
So you're not gonna shake my hand and let me walk out of here. Good for you
What do you want I am here to see if tales of the extraordinary being are true, may I meet the Beast
I'm Mary Reynolds
Need your abilities to get us all out of here
And show the world we exist
That sounds like the bad guys teaming up
Do you believe you are an avenging angel, partner?
I believe.  Avenge us. I have to get out of here before he gets out. They are contained
They always underestimate the mastermind
It has become David, I found someone who will require your full attention
You shouldn't be hiding in the shadows you might want to try and stop us
A lot of people are going to die
Now who'd like a PB and J sandwich
Finally all of us together for the world to see what we are capable of you need to get out of here
What have you done alight